this discussion on data science for
biologists
i must say i'm excited that we are
privileged to have this
in a to this session ongoing
i must say also that i'm
impressed to see the caliber of people
we have in contact
i believe you can all hear me loud and
clear before i proceed
distinguish ladies and gentlemen you are
welcome to data science for biology's
training program
in next six weeks we're going to have a
very interesting discussion
and training program where we expect to
have
outcome that would be beneficial to us
with good impact in genomic revolution
we will look at gen net generation
sequencing we'll also discuss
computational technology in various
areas
of research it is important for us to
note
that this program is designed for
those that have interest
in core research and we're talking about
biomedical biotechnology agrobiology
and particularly those that have
interest
in boundaries the research field
my name is sunny hamza
i'm a fellow with the medical library
science of nigeria
as a medical liberal scientist i'm
currently
a mentor and a fascinator for
omix logic nigeria
and eureka that is in partnership with
pine biotech
usa and today we are
to discuss and interact
to get the best out of the content we
want which wish to
put forth us for us to understand
today's session very much well
i will never take us through the
sessions that we're going to
be involved with now this program is
designed
for students and faculty members with
zero background in bioinformatics
to readily catch up and begin using
computational
tools right on without having any
formal training before by the end of
this program we expect
that researchers that have participated
as students
we'll go along thinking of how we can
conduct
and do our research work via
the content we are going to be giving us
to and we are going to have six sessions
the first session is going to be taking
care of today where we discuss the ngs
data
and genomic sequencing analysis then we
will have
a session on transcriptomics and
relationship
genomics we're also going to talk about
multiple sequence
alignments and phylogeny construction
then we'll talk about introduction to
machine learning
in biological data sets and finally by
this
session we'll talk about planning a
bioinformatics project
so we hope with your in
interest and interaction as much as
possible
if you go along with us we should be
able to put you through on
how you can do your research clearly
without any issues at the end of this
particular
program this is possible because of
a team of researchers and faculty
members
so we have faculty and trainers
that who interact with us really nice
program as follows we have dr harpris
cow that apple is a certified omix logic
trainer and expert by formation who will
guide us on hands-on session i also
assist the participants with projects
and analysis during the program her area
of specialization is in cancer genomics
and machine learning
we also have dr mohitz mazunder
is an omix logic project mentor and an
expert in biology
big data computational analysis dr
mazunder has a phd in computational
biology
and over 10 years experience
working with industry and academia
but we are excited to let us know that
we
we have for this this particular cohort
to be organized we're excited to let you
know that
the nigerian team have been put forward
to see that
this works out well well
and in our midst we have also a
distinguished
mr adekunle who happened to be a faculty
release at university
he is the director of ureca
we also have with us as a mentor and as
advocacy manager
doctor aditya aborigia who
also mentor us and also attend to all
our needs
as expected so this is the theme
that have been put forward to see that
we have good content
at the end of this discourse now going
to business
some of this ohmic science includes
genomics
the human genome is over three
billion base pairs long with over twenty
thousand genes
how many unexplored that
matter that is being explored
learning about the impact of variants
and all these content
is important for us to take note of so
today
our main discourse will be on how
we look at genomics then
later on x-ray next generation
sequencing as much as possible
when we listen about genomics what's the
first thing that comes to our mind
now the first thing that comes to our
mind when we talk about genomics
is for us to look at how how
some basic things come into together
now talk about the codes the gene how
they are passed from cell to cell
there about 3.2 billion liters in total
according to about
22 000 proteins now it is important for
us to note that
genes are made of bomb chemical entity
called
the dna which is
short of in short form called dioxide
nucleic acid
the dna molecule is a double helix
that is two long thin strands twisted
around each other like a spiral
staircase
the dna is the backbone of of each
strand
is made up of sugar and a phosphate and
is too strong interacting each other
with
that to the nuclear base it's important
for us to take note of
that for us to understand
and advance in the content we need to
get us to know
in humans generally speaking
g is varying in size from a few hundreds
dna based
to more than two million base
an international research effort called
the human genomic project
which work to determine the sequence of
human genome and then
identify the gene that contains that
human carriage estimated that we have
about 20 to
20 000 to about 25 000 genes
it is key for us to note that the
human it is the human gene lists
as we say it is hard to by estimate the
importance of the human journalists
series of studies have gone further to
understand this so that we can be able
to identify
disease-causing agents and understand
cancer or variance as it happens
some years back in 1990
a research work was taken over the
primary goal
of the human genomic projects the hgp
which lasted between 1990 to 2003
was it was to determine both the dna
sequence
and education as estimated with over 100
thousand human genes
now scientists make efforts to do this
research
understand how we can be able to lock up
a genomic
workup with identifying image
where it belongs to now at the end of
the day
what what came up was that
it's so massive that for us to be able
to move further
we need to get to understand certain
basics
now the basic includes that the dna is
made up of nucleotides
now this nucleus that we talked about
a nuclear is made of three components
the sugar called the oxidizers
the nitrogen containing a base and a
phosphate group
now the nucleotide as it is
as basic as possible i joined two
together
to one another by a covalent bond and
that
that's formed between the sugar of one
nucleotide
and the phosphate of the next resulting
to an
alternative sugar phosphate backbone
look at that of two complementary
strands
connected together are called
base pairs distinguish ladies and
gentlemen
these base pairs containing two strands
of dna when referring to the number of
base pairs containing in the dna
sequence
were called connected bases
each strand of the dna molecule consists
of a sequence base
that is complementary to the base in
opposing strands
and as you can see nuclei based
our four types we have the adenine
the guanine timing and
cytosine
[Music]
the basic thing we need to understand
here
is that this central dogma
when it comes to this is to understand
how we move from
the dna application down to
to transcription then translation
one question that should be borderless
in my mind is
with all these i have said so far how
are we able to push
through with the investment in negative
sequencing
what it has brought to us over the past
few years
according to the most laws
which says that
we can expect the speed and capacity of
our computers to increase every couple
of years
then we'll pay less to do
a full body sequencing
if you look at the cost of genome
in 2003 it cost you about a
hundred million dollars in 2017
it has less as a thousand
dollars that's to tell us that
with advancement in computer
it allows us to do a dry analysis
having data having information and doing
our sequencing as much as possible
to be able to have good interpretation
to do the need for when it comes to dry
research
one of the things that you should note
that when it comes to
next generation sequences it allows
researchers to explore
genetic variation like never before
down to a single nucleotide resolution
whether you need to identify a specific
variant from a focal set of region
or look more bravely to potential
positive
variation like a whole exam sequence
or a whole genome sequencing this is
very possible
and i think we should note that a whole
exome sequence is targeted and you can
easily view
the protein coding region of the
juvenile genome
now this also allows us a reliable and
sensitive
detection of code variants
now with engines it is faster and
cost effective you can imagine in 2003
to cost a hundred million
in 2017 is about a thousand dollars and
we are good to go
now we need to understand the types of
um next generation sequencing that we
need to
get basically there are
three we types looking at now as a
target targeted sequence requesting
here we can investigate
these i didn't specifically john from
our sample
and completing targeted sequencing
the targeted sequences provide us both
high coverage
and in-depth look at what's happening
within this specific region
now such localized sequence might be
useful
if you wanted to identify mutation that
you suspect
lead to a particular disease such as
cancer
also the target sequence works best
within the within
between the 440 to 400 genes
this also allows us it's ideal for
looking closely to small and small
specific region of genome it provides
high coverage of gene and allow us to
see
single base ps variation such as
insertion
and deletion it also generates small
amounts of
data potentially allow us to for easing
analysis
than some of the larger scale sequencing
techniques
then we also have the whole exam
sequencing
now the whole exam sequencing in order
for us to get this clearly
in order to first get it's on the large
scale
here we can run a whole enzyme sequence
which focuses on the protein codes
coding genes and it's
it gives the the brothers view
of the sequence now one of the things we
need to understand
is that the major advantage of whole
genome sequencing is that it allows us
to use both
coding gene sequencing and non-coding
region
providing us with more information about
the information
within the genome
now let us understand about the
different types of sequence
reads based on length size
of sequence now small read sequencing
up to 250 to 300 base pairs
up to now but the base play between 100
and 150
is still stranded the basic thing i want
us to take note here is that
when we have a hands-on session we were
able to explain clearly
about the small resequencing the
passable and the minion on
his short range and likewise the road
rage
as clear as possible for us to
understand and be able to apply
this now as regards
the for end for engines
we should note that we have short
read sequences and long release
requesters
now in your web lab this allows you the
opportunity
for you to do you necessarily need to do
and the data
have been translated for us to analyze
and get good outcome
so in next generation sequencing one of
the
important things we need to take home
with is that
when we get we move away from genomics
and we move down to transcriptome
sequence
is a major advance in the study of gene
expression
because it allows snapshot of the whole
skin tone rather than pre-vitamin
subject gene
the whole transcript sequence provides a
comprehensive view of cellular
transcriptomic profile
at a given vulcan moment and greatly
enhances the power of
rna discovery
now as we move along we are going to
explain to us
how this is possible
now let us understand how
this is allowed how this sets
was put in place the end is technology
captures the dna sequence
and generated digital data using several
steps
here we have the whole genome dna is
isolated
then it is shared shred and place it to
a flow cell
inside a flow cell the dna fragments
amplified
using the bridge pcr application
and the flow cell is then inserted into
a sequencer
the sequencer is a machine use image
analysis to capture
the each letter in the flow cell
fragment by analyzing visual pattern and
converting them to sequence letter
i did the t the c g
and a are seen here eventually it will
produce
reads typically between 300 between 330
to 300 base pairs
on that sequence data
is stored in several different file
formats
we have the first queue first a
gtf the sam and the bam
now the first q file provides us with
reads from the sequencer
it's a text-based file format that
stores nucleotide sequence
for of reads and the quality of
each letter the first r a
is a text-based format
for representing dna and protein
sequences typically this is
the reference file for the genome
then we'll go to the gta that is the
general transfer formats
then we'll talk about the sum and the
bomb
quickly let me just talk about um
the types of mutation so that we can
able to go to questions and answers
and do the needfully accordingly briefly
now usually dna is incredibly stable
and allow genetic codes to be maintained
i don't
ultimately pass from to on to the
upstream
despite the stability there are many
instances where there are some whether
changes in the dna now this gene chinese
nga
dna is as referred to as mutation
and they are and and when this happen
the mutations are characterized by the
change
it produces within the dna and we have
what we call
the point mutation point mutation
is as a result when there is
infiltration at a single base pair of
nucleotides and there are three types of
point mutations such as
as we know the substitution like what we
have you can see here clearly
insertion and deletion
in addition to point mutation that
affects the single base of the
business in dna there are also mutations
that can change you all
more than a sequence b single base
this can affect a whole session of the
dna
dramatically alternate gene expression
and protein
function for example
dna sequence that is that is insertion
improperly
of more times than normal results to
insertion mutation then an inversion is
a result when a sequence
of base reverse orientation within a dna
molecule
another type of mutation is called trans
location
transformation can happen between two
different types
in two different ways within the same
chromosome
and between two chromosomes
now let us look at some mutation that
can be encountered
and the impact that they have on genome
we have the first one known as mean
sense mutation
a genetic alteration in a single base
pair
substitution alters the genetic code in
a way
that produces the amino acid that is
different from the usual amino acids
at that position
some missense variation or mutation
will alter a function of the put
the repeating and it's also called
missense variation
then we also have what we call nonsense
mutation
now the nucleus mutation also involves a
single alteration of the dna
pressure however in a case of nonsense
mutation
this single change results in the
production
of a stop codon thereby terminating
protein
synthesis prematurely as a result
here there is incomplete protein from
that may
function or may not as such is known as
nonsense mutation and lastly we have
what we call
the frame shift mutation
now this occur when
when there's any addition or donation
that mutation result in a change of the
gene
reading from the frame which includes
group of three base that that is encoded
for the amino acids the change
in in the reading frame alters the group
of the base and subsequently changes the
amino acids
that is that i encoded as a result the
encoding protein becomes
non-functional and this is known as the
frame sheets shift
mutation
also when we talk about
codons and amino acids
a change at even
at a single base level can it can be
enough to change the type of protein
expressed
so let us see what happens each amino
acid
is represented in the dna of a set of
three base pairs
referred to as a codon that is a
t and c
a mutation in codon sequence can result
to a change
in the amino acid produced
the result in altering the structure and
the function of the protein
if you look at this table clearly
you will see clearly
here how how a codon could impact the
amino acid expressed
those both insertion and addition can
change the dna sequence
and the rna and the protein level by
changing a particular codon and that is
clearly seen
when a change occur
lastly i want to just let us know that
was the significance
of a dna variation
so far so good
when there is any movement mutation
happen it plays a significant role
particularly in cancer development
or better we say in the drive of tumor
formation
as we all know there are various
important genes
that play key roles in cell cycle and
regression of cell growth
any disturbance in those genes
will definitely cause a challenge
in in the outcome
of the of the of the codon that exists
now it is click for us to take notes
that as researchers
we need to first understand the dna
understands how
mutation occurs then how
the implication of this happening
now when it comes to engines
the reality that comes to play is that
it allows us to
express ourselves and ensure that when
analysis is done and
you have data you can be able to
do the needful accordingly to see that
the data you have got you so far can
analyze
and put into perspective in the next few
minutes
we're going to take questions
i'll post for now and um
we're going to have a a live session
for us to understand how we need to
apply what i've said so far
we have just talked about one of the
omics today and today we are talking
about
genomics we want to talk about
transcriptomics and metagenomics
before we now talk about the machine
language
so the next few minutes i'm going to
post now
and attend questions via the chat box
so you have your questions we appreciate
you put your question in the chat box
while that is going on i would like to
introduce down to the platform
to allow us to contribute to do live on
session
with um doctor aditya borishadi because
he's a community manager and also a
mentor a facil
he's going to run through the genomic
pipeline
and explain to us how we are going to
apply what we have learned so far
in the real world particularly running
our pipelines and having
hands-on what we have discussed so far
so in next few seconds
we want us to put our questions on the
chat box
then um we will be calling dr boisha to
come on board
thank you mr sonny then share your
screen now
so we can go
thank you mr sunderland thank you
everyone
it's glad to have you there and
i hope you can all hear me
anyway i would love to start with the
question
from david akul it's asking
how that kind of poor dna sequencing
analysis leads to mutation
david if i'm correct that's your
question
hello david
so the maybe
the best way to answer this question is
maybe i should try and rephrase the
question in a bit
to make all of us understand
now even if the goal of next generation
sequencing
is to be able to sequence data
from our samples be it
the tissue sample sampled from the blood
or serum
or meta metagenomic sample evamator
samples
but ngs is not perfect
right and that's why in a fast q format
there are quality scores attached to
each call it is not
every a that could behave once
engineers cause an a it gives you a
quality score that tells you
how reliable is that score right
so that the first thing you do when you
have squares data
is to do what we call data
pre-processing
and part of data processing is such that
you'll be able to trim away pcl
duplicates
and poor cause cause with low quality
bases
so when this is done your chances
of actually getting a true mutation
and not poor dna sequencing will be low
right so the first thing we do after
sequencing data is to
data processing which we do which
removes
pcl pistol duplicates which removes
adapters and trimmers
and which removes low quality bases once
this is done
any variant you get any mutation you
call
has a high reliability so the
dna sequence itself will not cause
mutation
but poor weeds might give you might make
you presumed as a mutation
and there are robust biologic algorithm
choose to prevent this and minimize it
to
a small amount so david i'm sure you
understand that
thank you mr sunny for a very
comprehensive
introduction to ngs
and genomics and for most of us
some of us are clinicians medical lab
scientists
modern molecular biologists are
molecular scientists so we are not we
are familiar with most of these things
and the first question if you ask is
why time biotech what's the essence of
this
logic data why are we doing this
what is our goal how do we plan to
make this community research oriented
and vast in bioinformatics
and the way pi biotech has done this is
by creating a couple or a plethora of
educational resources before i go on
directly to the amazon sessions
i want to introduce us to these tools
that prime biotech has as a company
to effectively communicate and convey
to the basics the knowledge of
bioinformatics
please go me to
explore the first
the first two it's the so-called
land.org logic platform please let me
know if you can see my screen
can i see my screen
okay thank you dr nancy so this first
data set is the line
is the land.only logic.com
i'll put this on the chat form so we can
all have access to it
the length please use https
learn dot omics
logic logic.com
this is the first educational portal
pine bowl take us and in this portal if
you're coming even if you're not going
to join us for this program
you can still register for free and
utilize
all the available educational resources
if this is your first time on this
platform just click on register for free
where you'll be led to sign up
i'm already logged in so i'll log out
again so that i can do this app issue so
click on register for free
if you're a new user create an account
input your name
your email address and your password
then click sign up
right i'm already registered so i'll
just click
sign in and it takes us back to this
platform
right please how many of us are here
or how many of us are having issues to
come here how many of us are here
so we can take it step by step the
landowmixlogic.com
go to home register for free
if you're a new user you create an
account enter your preferred name
your email address and an appropriate
password
then click on sign up once that is done
you're back to this page and the first
thing you see in this page
are cites my username the points i've
been able to accrue
my level if i click on this there are
many things that i've done
you'll see all the achievements all the
courses completed
all the lessons all the steps and all
the code blocks that i've run
right if i click on this
you can see the same thing these are all
the codes that i've run on this platform
right but if you're not interested there
just click on the courses
submia most of
the all the courses are not free there
are premium courses on this platform
however all the courses are free for
registered participants if you are
registered on
any of our programs like this one we are
starting today
you will have access to all these
courses but if not
there are a lot of free courses on this
platform
so once you click on the courses you see
a breakdown
of all the available costs right
for most of them there are questions on
introduction to bioinformatics
you can either go to this way or you can
just chat search for
because for example today's topic is
genomics
let me type genomics and see
this is the cause of genomics is the
course three on this platform
and genomic has eight lessons that will
take an approximate
10 hours to complete right and you can
see that
i have completed genomics nine times as
a clinician
genomics and transatomics is my forte so
i have i'm
always coming back to genomics because
on this platform
you are you always have new things to
learn
and if you go down you'll see that the
dna structure and variant that mr sunny
educators are about there not only is it
head you can see this one is len
this is an asyquos well-paced
theoretical background right and you can
see here you can see that this is
our code meaning that on this platform
you also have access to learning
coding via out as you can see here
so these are codes these are the theory
this is the code
so you do the theory and you do what you
learn the codes
if i'm interested in other courses for
example
if you're interested in translito mix
you can log out you can click
transcriptomics
you see that it cost six on this
platform
which consists of 29 lessons
29 lessons on transcomics
right and if you go down you see the
breakdown this
when you still land those are a
synchronous
self-paced courses that gives you the
theoretical basis
of a multi-omics model
right you see all this land
if you click load more
if you click on load more more less
things will be loaded
i can see on under transdominic's pca
supervised machine learning all these
courses with
these yellow diamond images
they are premium courses either you
access the program by paying for a
program
or you go to each of these individual
courses
and make payment for them payment which
is between
10 to 45 depending on
the cost you pick but
as i said i can assure you i can say
that most of all these
courses also have free resources
right that you can avail yourself off
so this is our first platform that i
would love to introduce us to
for new users kindly just go on
like we said earlier register yourself
and avail yourself of this the
other platform which prime biotech also
has
is known as the server t-bow dot
info i also love to
put this on the chat forum so we can see
it
the server.info
right now this is the main platform
where we run all the bioinformatics
model bioinformatics analysis
and today i want some of them
if you have an overview of this platform
you can see that there are different
submodules
depending on what data you want to
analyze this is for ngs data
and underneath it you can see
transcriptomics genomics
dna you also have max
spectroscopy data you also have
the data integration of modeling right
where here you can see
it can do all robust
advanced data analysis supervised
machine learning
or supervised machine learning factor
analysis and diversity expression
all this can be done either with your
own personal
data or with sample data sets
that have been integrated on to the
system
right today we'll see some of those demo
data sets
for example if you follow me and click
this you can see all this demo
demo demo these are the sample data sets
that have been computed
on this platform right server.tbow.info
is an artificial intelligence
smart cloud-based server
where at the touch of a button you can
perform
bioinformatic analysis right you don't
need to
upload because molecular biology data
is big data it is large in volume
you can do analysis one into 45
gigabytes and much more 20 gigabytes
and this money that stress your system
or you might need to actually utilize
your super computer and a resource
oriented
setting like us how many universities
have super computers
how many labs have smart computers right
pybow tech has maneuvered around this
circumspectly by the production of this
platform which is cloud-based
meaning you get your data and was loaded
on the cloud
and this platform we want it for you
right
that's the second platform
so are we here to are we following along
any questions
any questions about the platforms
yes david not only can you work with our
right you can also work with python
there's a third
server that will that's also another
platform which has somehow been
integrated in that first one
but if your goal is just to run codes
then this site is for you the
code.oxley.com
which is our thought size right let me
first make it clear
that we are not planning to make you add
call coders
we are just teaching you step by step
coding that is relevant
for bioinformatics this is i also put
this on the chat forum
the code.org.logic.com which is
in it has been integrated into the
learn.logic.com
but if you still want to do coding and
which that's
what it's actually what you want to do
you can just make use of this website
it's called.omixlogic.com right i'm a
store in peternick on the chat forum
also here you can just come here get
started
create an account like elia and
continue using it there are a lot of
free courses
right but he also asked some
some premium courses where you probably
also need access to
this opening and you see just like the
other platform
you have things to do but here not only
will you work on owl
but for some of them you also work on
python
so to answer the vgs you also have some
python codes
that are both on the platform and this
right
so these are the three websites three
educational
platforms where you can go and learn
each
of the multi-omics genomics
transmitomics
metagenomics and also advanced data
analysis
machine learning and use this analysis
to visualize your data to
understand your data to predict
patterns from your data and to interpret
cogent patterns from your data
and lastly we also have
projects that have been
projecting studies that are
part and parcel of this land length
dot com where you can
learn how some authors
how they've done analysis how they've
analyzed
and gotten reasonable meaning from their
data
for example you can see this is a
project which is tcga
liver cancer project right
you can see here this is a step-by-step
analysis of this publication how the
authors analyzed
each step before it became
a published data and is
domiciled in ncbi not only this
you also have other projects this is a
project involving
convert 19 and the participants of star
school 2 right
almost six lessons you can go to each of
them
and learn how you can make use of these
multimixed data
in arriving at a sensible circumspect
and clinically relevant
outcomes from your data right
so all these and many more
can be found on all our platforms
and all these and many more will also be
taught throughout the duration
of this program starting from today
which is the first session
it's going to be a six weeks once weekly
program right to cut short on
the theories to
further butcher us what mr sonny has
talked about
let's in the next few minutes
losing or learn
how do we visualize genomic data
for clinicians you have
a patient they are managing either for
an infectious disease
or for a cancer
and because of availability of ngs
you have been able to
sequence either from the sample
the tissue sample or from blood fluids
like serum blood or other availability
and now what do you first do
what do you do to this data for medical
lab scientists
you have done with the wetland
you have started the dna you have done
all that should be done what else can
you do
to the to your samples after piecing one
or what next to be done
right this is the dry lab aspect
of analysis and the first thing we'll do
is what we call how do you visualize
your genomic data all right as i said
earlier
there are working site demo data sets
which i would love to make use of them
right so
for people who have access please just
kindly go with me to this
server dots about the info
and let me know where you're there i
want us to go through it together
so that i can this program is a path
hands-on
we do step by step together if i'm too
fast you can call me back
right please once again server
dot see
the information is just click on it
and let me know why you are there
right if you are there you can just say
yes or put one in the chat forum
i would take some few seconds to wait
for you
thank you
thank you cynthia thank you
thank you very much mr sunny please if
you can
for people that don't have access
there's a demo access which you can use
to just follow along with that sony kind
kindly help me put the demo assets
on the platform or give me a second let
me
impute a demo access so that everyone of
us there can have access to it thank you
everyone thank you zudin thank you ben
okay
so this is a demo access you can use
you can use that username as you come to
the access you can use this username
test at pineblogtech.com and use that
password
thank you elaborate on that will give
you access
to this right so because what we are
working on
is genomics and is what is genomic data
so scroll down to this genomic aspect
right
and if you click on this arrow beside
mutation variants
we have these three demo
data sets that we can make use of for
today's visualization
i would love to click on this variant
calling
these are for cell lines if time permits
i will also try and visualize this code
too
if possible but let's start with this
first so once we click on this
right
we are faced with this plethora of
tools
of bioinformatic tools right
and these tools will allow us to do
any analysis whatsoever on our genomic
data
but remember the first thing i said was
that before you want a data analysis
there are various steps right and these
steps are also highlighted
in this server if you look at this place
if i magnify this a bit the first thing
you see is what
data pre-processing we just don't want
we
know that ngs itself
is not 100 accurate we could have
some products from poor weeds
right in the process of ngs we made use
of
adapters we've made use of pcr
duplicates
and we need to remove all this
so that our data can be reliable
while we begin to call variance right so
the first step
here is what is known as data processing
and where we can use any of these tools
we can use pcl claim to clean piece of
duplicate
we can use trimatic to trim adapter
sequences
and also trim poor weeds right
that's the first step we do most times
when you have your data this is the
first step
but in this case because our data has
been cleaned before inculcation into
this
website into this platform we're not
going to do
processing today the first the next step
which is the first step we're going to
do is
why you take samples for
analysis why take samples
how do you know which part
of the genome mr sunny said
our genome is 3.2 billion nucleotides
when we run our weeds how do we know
exactly
where these reads are coming from
is it from chromosome 1 is it from
chromosome 22
or is it from sex chromosomes x and y
we first need to be able to align them
first before we can begin to read any
meanings into
either there's a mutation here there is
a prediction there
or there's a variation otherwise right
so if
after data processing the next step is
what we called
mapping or alignment
right where we align the result of our
weeds
to a control known as the reference
genome
right and that's what we do and
this algorithms star
bwa and bowtie two who
give us the chance to do this meaning
once i click start meaning i want to
start this i'll
alignment this process i'll click okay
you can see two things are you
considerate are happening
i said our server is smart and hearing
it
the first you can see that some cells
become what they become yellow
meaning the platform is telling me my
next option
is to process with this or map with this
as i said earlier this is a demo data
set
and progress has already been done i'm
just
interested in what in mapping our weeds
to the reference genome so and i'll make
use of but i too to do that
once i click but i too this would
explain what butter 2 does and
if you read from here is for what
aligning sequence reads
to large reference genomes right and it
is designed to work with the range of
mid length from 50
up to thousands so this is what this is
going to do for me
now i've clicked bow tie 2 right
if you check next something else is
already visualization is what is already
being highlighted
meaning visualize
my genomic read right and this also
there are various genome browsers we can
use for this
we have jeb gauss we have igv
and we have ucsc but the j browse the
genome browser
which has been fully integrated into
this platform
so i'll click ok that all i want to do
is visualize
if you check this you say that the next
item to be elected is to end my pipeline
right which i also go ahead and click on
end
this pipeline is complete how many
people have been able to follow with me
this far
but david we are working on human genome
and the imaginative version is imputed
on this but on this t server
so this is hg-38 that we're working on
detected build
is the reference genome weapons genome
for
each means
genome for that species right the human
reference genome
project which got a lot of money
and took almost between 11 to 13 years
was completed in 2001
so now we have a reference human genome
where we can use as control
for all leads from humans and not only
that
plants some animals and mammals also
have the reference genome
meaning once you take any weed
from this specie you can align into the
reference genome
and to tell you the location position
chromosome off your leads
right miriam
please just copy and paste it is it is
very case sensitive
please try it again just copy and paste
right
have you been able to follow me to this
point please if you have just press
just type one or put yes so that will
know
or you have to take a step back a bit so
that others can follow along
thank you dr litung thank you elvis
thank you mujib
thank you zuden felix
where exactly was the problem
thank you doctor touga
xenapp you came late because of felix
i'm not because of you
just a step back you're saying both
in the next few seconds let me just
repeat this cycle right
i'm saying in this case
what we want to do is analyze ngs data
right so we had ngs data
for now you can also make use of your
individual data sets
but for the for this for today for this
practice
i want to make use of a sample data set
that is domiciled in this platform right
and if i if you click this you see
three demo data sets right you have
variant calling lines you have sas cov2
that's the copyright symbiose and for
ebola
so i'm saying i want to make use of this
this pipeline
for a cell line right once i click on it
it brings me to this pitot of tools
and shows me the various processes
depending on what you want to do
right now i'm saying for all data the
first thing to do
is to is what we call the type of
processing where you
clean your data to remove
poor quality bases pcl duplicates
adapter sequences so that whatever
results you get downstream can be
reliable
right so i said on this platform
you have all this to do that after
process the next thing to do is to align
your data your sequencing data to a
reference genome
if it's if this details from humans you
align it to the human reference genome
if it was from
that of mouse you are lying to the
reference genome of musculus
it is from other animals you also align
it
right what that does is that it shows
you exactly
where your widths map to right
and i said the tools for this is star
bwa and bowtie 2
right and i said for today's what we
just want to do today is visualize our
genomic data
we have done work lab we have sequences
let's visualize it right so i said once
you click start
meaning you want to start the pipeline
you click ok
because it's already a process data set
i don't want to use pcl claim
right what i want to do is just map to
the reference genome so i'll click on
button 2
right but i to work you can see here it
says but that is an algorithm for
aligning sequence reads to large
reference genomes
i click on this now you can see every
step of the way
the platform is telling me what to do
what to do next
it's giving me options alternatives but
here is that only give me one
alternative which is to visualize
so i click on visualization it also
gives me a
small just small info about what i
should expect right
i click on okay right when i'm done it's
telling the next step which is to end
this pipeline like my goal is to
visualize
i'm done with this pipeline and i hand
right when i end i click
ok when i click okay
this is my a result
the pipeline that i judge one that i did
but i do to map
i visualize and end this is the result
the result is in this output file which
is
demo public output file and if you look
at it carefully
you can see this button this blue button
is showing visualization
right if i go ahead and click
as you can see what is happening it has
opened
one of our genome browsers known as
jbrowse can you see jbrowse is a genome
browser
and that is the preferred brow the
preferred genome
browser for server dot info
right let me magnify this so you can see
clearly
let me also minimize it right
so what we can see here is
these are the samples
we have group one and group two right
we also have the reference sequence so
let me kindly click on one of the
samples so that we can see
so this is someone
and you can see all these color changes
this is
the samples that i've read this is these
samples
being aligned to the reference genome
let me let me minimize so that we can
see clearly
i think he's okay here
okay so the first thing you observe
is if you keep running if you keep
if you keep moving this around you see
these red and blue lines right
you see some empty spaces in between
these red
and blue lines these are our sequences
these are our sequences
right and if you look at this
these numbers these numbers mean
positions
on the reference genome meaning
at position 100 000
you have the sequences at position 150
200 you have the sequences if i minimize
more
you'll be able to see them clearly then
if i want to go to any position for
example let's assume
i want to go to position 50 000 i'll
just click on it
did you take a while to load
no then up you don't need j browse
installed
right you just go
if you're coming you can either open
your box directly by yourself
or some adoptee boundary for whooping
directly for yours we open it directly
for you automatically
because it is integrated with the
platform
dr raja i'm not neglecting where i'm
calling
right vance call is also one of the
things we do under genomics
and if you're a part of the last quote
we have
gone to beyond calling which
aggressively
and
compressively right today we're just
trying to show how to visualize data
the alcohol is another aspect where we
go with time permits us
so what we have seen here
peaks are showing
the coverage of asic
of our weeds are these places
and at this point i begin to see the
sequences
if you keep
magnifying this you can see that
the position is already written as
chromosome one so what we are doing now
is visualizing chromosome one
if we click on this we can visualize
any aspect of the chromosome even
chromosome x and y
but basically we are visualizing what
comes from one and what position comes
from one we're
resizing four eight to nine this to this
which is 21.26 kb that's going to be
obviously presently
right and let's just focus on this
segment
right you focus on this
this is a sequence
that has been aligned to the reference
genome
right and want to see the reference
sequence let's keep zooming
you see these are the individuals
gt gta
sequences this is the reference genome
right
so what does this mean these colors
what do they mean individually
what knowledge can we gain from this
right
once you see a red color it means this
is what a positive strand it is a what a
forward strand you know dna is
coming pierce the forward and reverse
strand
so this red means this is a fourth
strand
why this blue means is a reverse strand
right
if you click on to get more information
about this
you click on it and opens this right
it tells us the sample the total quality
score
the position and the strand without
possible
negative then it gives us this
each sequence and the quality
call of each sequence right
we can also see the length of this this
is a 101
base pair sample
just 101 right all these information
are available right
this if the only thing you need is
the weed of this sample this is the read
this is the first a weed of this sample
it's just a t tcc
and so on and so on and so on let's
click on the blue sample
to understand that if you see a blue
somebody consider that the first thing
is it is
negative meaning what is the reverse
strand
right the sequence and quality of which
is also shown
right j brows gives us a lot of
information
if you can see that even though this are
both
shades of red this is lighter
right it's telling us that this
lighter sample
as a it is not properly paired
or the qualities are not as high as this
right
even for blue you can see that this is
blue this is
almost faint blue all these are more
can all this information can be gotten
from this
right and also you can also see
this is the total coverage of this
segment you can see this is very high
right
and if you click on this it will tell
you that a total of 571 reads
right aligned to this reference genome
right and this information can go a long
way
in making us visualize our sample so if
i'm looking at this sample
i know that it has aligned to this
segment but
there's zero alignment to the segment
please are there any questions are we
following through
if you don't understand anything please
kindly put it in the chat phone
right
so this is how to visualize
our data the word
for positive strand the blue for
negative strand i can see if you compare
alignment here and alignment you can
start this is very low
right so for david if i'm trying to
do variant calling in this region i will
be very circumspect
because the coverage is what is very low
but if you come to this place you can
see that the coverage
is high enough and sufficient
to be able to call invariant or
imitation but here you can see that air
is very low
yeah is also very low right
so these are factors you put
into consideration
all i'm looking inside you need your
reference genome
the reference genome is inculcated in
gibrals
and you can see that this sequence
let me zoom in so that you can see
this sequence here this first sequence
is the reference genome right
and anywhere there is duration
will be shown this here you can see
reference sequence
this is the reference genome this
is only showing our sample
that has been aligned to the reference
genome right
so dr tumba
what quality score of the code that
makes it a sequence reliable
from emmanuel
usually this is this is the out
repetitive this is
this is the second chord so most of
these topics have been dissected
in our first quarter if you start out
the mail at africa
bow we'll try and link you up with
resources
and probably videos session videos that
make you understand
effectively what quality scores are
right
what is what is what what are threat
equality scores
right it is it's not a session right
but some of the mail at africa apart
about and i assure you
we'll give you enough resources
that will make you understand what
exactly fair quality scores are
right please do
you can if you also go to genomics one
or learn automaticology.com
which is free right it will also give
you
more insight into thread quality scores
and quality scores of sequencing data
thank you very much so any more
questions any more questions
felix go to lan.omicslogic.com
right go to genomics introduction to
genomics genomics one which is
absolutely free
this this will be you you will learn
more about this quality scores
and how to either trim them away
before you start your downstream
analysis or how to include them
industrial analysis
thank you very much there are no
questions
yes david you can
let me click on this
david you know especially when we come
to
our coding platform right once you have
this sequence
you can go to how and use bounce strings
to calculate dc percentage
you can calculate the dc percentage of
the all
sample of different windows
maybe part this is called this is
percentage of
android bases of training business or
auto title samples right
the calculation is not automatically
done in jeep girls
jpg house is basically to just visualize
see
where the changes are see the coverage
for example you can see that this
this place has a high coverage why some
places have low coverages right that's
especially what g
g brush is for but if you want to know
the gc percentage
that's also possible right i can do that
either on out
which if you go ahead to genome genomic
one or genomics two
and they are coding you'll be able to
learn how to
check for dc content of the sample
either
the total sample or segments of that
sample
but we all know the function of gc
content and it is possible
so thank you very much david
our time is first spent so i will not be
able to show us
or we won't be able to visualize the
other aspect of it which is
sask of two but as dr raja mentioned
what is the essence of visualization
if you're not going to call it variance
right
can we do variant calling via
our platform and the answer is
definitely yes
right and in the next five minutes or
very few minutes
i'll quickly run and show us how to
call
variants for the so-called mutation v
and calling on this platform
right here is also
probably also used one of these data
sets as you can see
the title of this is what mutation
variance parallel analysis of mutation
variance
what does what do we mean by that as mr
sunnyvale said
even though replication is
almost perfect it is still imperfect
and when the dna is replicating itself
it makes a mistake of one base in
every one thousand applications one in
one thousand bases there is a mistake
right and these mistakes can be points
or can affect a sizeable number
right and it has been proven that
some success ability to infections
some cancers some differences
in genotype and phenotype are due to
these mutations are due to these
durations
so for every sample you have the your
goal
might be to know what are the cause of
this disease
what are the cause of this cancer right
because of this susceptibility
is as a result of any of this mutation
what are singular promotions or
mutation affecting like segments of the
genome
so let's also use this variant calling
right and i said earlier if you have
your own data set you can use it but for
the purpose of this demonstration
we'll do this right we click start as
usual
you can clean if you want to in this
case because we are doing something more
more robust so let's clean after
cleaning what do we do
we do bow tie meaning we map
to to
i can see the next thing that i shown is
differential variant calling it's taking
us to this
bioinformatic tool known as striker
right striker is a tool that is used to
call for
variations in sample weeds i'll click on
striker
right after striker it tells us what
he's going to do
then we click on ok then if you want to
use somatic sniper
you can right
maybe i should use some magic sniper
just so to fully explain it to us
then i click on somatic sniper then i
click on
end
this is a typical pipeline
to call variants you start
pcrocking for processing both type 2 for
mapping
striker and sniper somatic sniper for
the division
beyond calling and you hang it right as
usual
your result will be here right
and if you want to see your results you
must you have to click his output so let
me keep this output and download it
how many people who are also able to
follow along
that is can you hear me now
okay every please check your audio
i think the others can hear me right
so if you if you're able to follow along
so far just click yes or one
okay thank you office maybe it was a
network problem
thank you everyone thank you cynthia
thank you david so
once you click on this you realize that
it has downloaded
so let me just go to my downloads and
access
okay
so this is the output file and if i open
it
you can see right now
variant calls ah
formatted in the file format known as
vcf
we aren't calling formats right and this
can only be viewed
with resources such as igv
you're right but when you use somatic
sniper
it gives you results in a table like for
my case that is an excel format
let me open this and to
we can glean more information from this
so if you are there please
once you open it up you have this dot
xlx which can open in excel
you also have this which will open later
in igv but for now
let's open this let's see what
information we can glean
from this before we come back right can
we still see my screen
okay please the video we made available
you can
watch the video later and follow on the
platform
right thank you very much
so here you can see this information
the first thing you can see is the
chromosome
is shown right and all these are in
chromosome 1
and if you keep going you see that this
will actually show you
individual chromosomes right
that's the first information you get
that's the first line
you see individual chromosomes then on
each chromosome
you see the positions now what
when you call it variant it's not going
to show you
every aspect of the genome that's not
its job
right it's going to show you the aspect
of the genome
where there are variations right
it will show you come on to come from
20. if there's a version comes from one
it will show if that revolution comes on
the left it will show right
so don't expect to see all the genome we
are visualized with j
brows what we are doing is what we
called
variant calling we want to see where
variations are so this is chromosome
these are the positions
where these are variations and this is
what is very interesting which i want
you to see
that the reference based on the genome
is what is what is available here
let me click on this
now here you are expecting to see what a
c
right
and when we did our sampling
our sequencing reads we have two samples
one sample for the tumor one sample for
the normal
right please i hope you can all see
please because please let me know how
it's like nothing because
so on the normal
sample you can see that the reference is
still what
you still see meaning
there has been no change in normal to
your symbol
but on the tumor you can see that what
is written here is
m right
if you are familiar with iu pack of
codes we know that not only do we have
hcgt we also have others
like m means this is an amino base right
if you also send us a mail or for the
people that restart participants
who send you the iu pack of codes you
know what
m means
are we together
so but one thing is true
that in this tumor what you have is not
what
is not c i m actually means either a or
c
right but in this in the normal it is
definitely c
but for the variance it can actually
could have been an a right and the
reason i said so is
if you not check the somatic score which
is what somatic sniper will do for you
the higher this call the more likely it
is
that this is a mutation a true mutation
and that it could also have costs or
have led to the
carcinogenesis in this case right
for example this score is high enough to
say oh
this could be a true somatic score right
just by looking at these
first five
fields you can get a lot of information
right for example let's look at another
one
let's have number 10 in number 10
the reference base is c normally c right
but tomorrow is m here the reference
base is g
normal is g but the tumor is k
right in k k means it can k means the
ketone
right meaning it can be a g or what
or a t but if you look at here is that
this somatic
chord is what is very low
so it's likely that this is not really a
true mutation even if it was a true
mutation
it might not have been the cause for
these mutagenesis
right
no z now the reference base
and the normal are not always the same
there could be variations right there
are combinations
these are things we'll discuss fully
later
the time is first spent at this point
i would just like to ask for more
questions
and i need to invite the program
director to
lap up if you have more questions you
can
send us questions at africa at pound
bao right
i'm putting this segment again
for the register participants please
send your questions on our whatsapp
forum on our slack form
and all your mentors will look at
international deal with it
if you still want to be part of this
program to learn more about genomics
transphobics
please you can still join right
this was made free so that you can be
encouraged to join part of this program
if there are no further questions i
would like to answer at this point
so mr dekule who end up sessions
as i said earlier please you can see
drop your questions
consider us email after
and you can also call us
right to get more information about this
program thank you very much
over to you
is
good evening everyone and it's been a
wonderful time so far
thank you dr editorial for that very
um section
now quickly um i like to
just hear my screen us quickly through
few information sessions
to guide us moving forward in this
program please i hope you can hear me
clearly
yes we can yes we can okay great
thank you very much all right so um
yes we've begun this journey data
science for biologists
and um in the next um six weeks
we will be working together to
learn about um
how to process and analyze how to
detoxify
understand the logic behind them and
ultimately
one of the you know these ones i look
forward to
on this particular training is the
project
you know develop your own projects
and section that will be taken so that
every participant from beginning
think around using and you know
presets and biological uh i'm sorry by
information
analyze this data set
of an endeavor
okay so um already as we may
be aware the traditional have scaled
because the number
[Music]
of participation which is available to
everyone
that meets in minimum
requirements for getting certificate of
participation
and of course there will be certificates
of excellence equally for those who
reach
the you know the ten thousand point
milestone that is you know allowable for
that
um quickly these are some of the
certificates
um from security of excellence and by
some of the participants of our past
trainings
and i know it is very much possible that
is ten thousand points and i look
forward to
seeing many of us on this cohort also
attaining that
equally we have this is the circuit of
pursuit participation
as an example for us to see um i'd like
to move on to say that
our goal for this training remains that
we want to build
a community of researchers and so like
previous programs
um you know organized you know um you
know globally in other
in other centers where we have
participants going on to
our own and execute their own research
is using
you know bioinformatic tools and equally
presenting before before they are
you know colleagues in in
sessions like conferences and workshops
just like what we see here
on the screen so we look forward to
achieving that as a matter of fact
the line towards the end of the year
there will be an opportunity
for participants from our various
previous programs
to present their works in
france and section so we look forward
that is the goal so we are not here just
to
um just to talk about these things or to
take
resources and platforms mentoring guide
many of the questions that were being
asked during the live sessions today
we see how to continue on our slack page
uh mean overall and interaction so
comments questions should be posted on
that platform
and mentors any of the mentors both
local men and
locally here in nigeria as well as our
international mentors
will be quick to respond to your
questions and give you the necessary
guidance
so um and these are the things we look
forward to and just
remind us um
you know during this program um section
two be focusing on transcriptomics
um i'd like to remind us that um it's a
session that
um we look at the ethereals um
you know aspect of gene expressions and
the quantification of these expression
levels so
um i encourage us for to join that
session
um next week um also section three would
be on metal genomics we already have the
um the flyers but these are some of the
things we look into
we look at how my cougar communities and
you know
live our function together affecting
you know biological and science fields
like agriculture health the environment
and the rest
during that session we reportedly move
on to take a look at multiple sequence
alignments and family genetic analysis
uh
that will be during section four and in
section five
we'll be taking machine learning machine
learning and so
these are all lens to serve as
introductory
um you know faces to guide participants
on these journey to into bioinformatics
and section 6 you can mention earlier
will be on
planning a bioinformatics project so
i look forward to having us all you know
come on board and join the program and
importantly i'd like to
talk now about the assignments for
against i mean next week
next section which will be coming up
next with wednesday
we expect participants to register and
complete their profile
on the land.com logic platform
of course after registering the tbr
server today we're given
a demo access and loading details
i can very much i assure you that has a
lot of limitations
it is just meant for the demo sessions
but for every participant of the program
you'll be getting an email with a full
access to the entire
server dot ebal 8. info platform so that
is one of the reasons you should
register
so that the you know data sets will be
using during the training
you can equally analyze them um you know
and take advantage of that platform
so register and complete your profile
part of which will be
or sending you um the assets your
personal login access to that server as
well as other resources
i also want to encourage every of the
person to
go on and complete the courses
on the learn.omislogic platform ensure
before next session you have completed
the introduction to bioinformatics
we have some participants from previous
um programs
also here in this cohort i encourage at
your spare time
you should equally look at them because
there are some configurations i mean on
some additions to those um courses
um i will share the the links
for these the titles for the
introduction to bioinformatics is
pipes from molecules so it is not you
won't see it as
introduction to bioinformatics on that
platform importantly i want
us to look at the genomies course and
also
lay our hands on the transcriptomies i
think the genomics has
about six um courses i mean
packaged together in that kind but
lacrosse lessons package together in
that course
also let us uh you know complete the
transcriptomics course
um we'll be looking at transcriptomies
next session so
it will be very much uh you know at an
advantage to have taken the task
too many course completed so that you
move at a very
um understanding and
you know getting all of the things that
will be shared during the
live sessions and i only want to
encourage all participants
um during this next six weeks to the
game to work on the project one and
project three
which are series of projects that have
been taken from
you know scratch i mean from the very
beginning
to um to the very end analyzing
and you know looking at cov19 for
example the origin of pathogenesis
how it was sequenced and you know if um
you know one can
identify the various variants recalling
on project two is ebola virus
and here for those of us who are very
much interested in mutations
this will provide us with good and
understanding of
all that has been discussed today and of
course the assignment says is
for us to run demo pipelines as much as
possible
you know while taking those courses
so um without a do the other thing i
would like to
mention is just to introduce us to the
various social media platforms
but we can still always do much of this
moving down the line
we have a linking page and a linkedin
group
which i encourage every participant to
join
so as to be getting all of the
informations and industry
opportunities openings and the rest that
is available scholarships and
i mean all of the duties regarding the
bioinformatics for big data
analysis feed so i'm joined on linkedin
group
um um we probably we
have our facebook page you can connect
with us
and also for um juror card which is the
omis logic africa team we have
our hands on twitter
um facebook and instagram where you can
follow us and
interact with us i'd like to encourage
your support to come along
and join all of these um
and social media platforms um
so on that note i'd like to end this
session today
time is fast-paced we want to appreciate
everyone who
made it to this point with us and look
forward to
you know interacting further with you
and engaging
with you um down the line so if there
are any questions please quickly you can
ask but please do not hesitate to reach
us
for those who are here to join or who
want links to some of these
uh you know resources that i've shared
on anything you have that you'd like us
to
to support country respond to please do
not hesitate to write us at
africa fine don't bow africa find the
bell
and you can equally try to chat us up on
our social media
pages we will respond to you so on that
note i'd like to
end this session today except where
there is any questions
or comments quickly
do we have any
so great um it's been a wonderful time
this evening we appreciate everyone who
was able to join us
so we meet again next week wednesday
however
the training continues tomorrow it's
continuous lists
tomorrow friday and all along
until we meet during another live
session next week
so for paid participants for those who
want to join
the training has not stopped the live
session really returned next week
the training continues take advantage of
the materials and the resources on the
platform
so as to um to us to
get the very best of the premium assets
you have
okay um i think that is what i would say
because after six weeks
for those who are even paid participants
those premium processes will return to
being premium
even for you meaning you won't be able
to access them so why determine us
please kindly you know do the very best
maximizing and all of these premium
courses
and then good night everyone see you on
this large channel
and on other platforms thank you
you